Well, in the same way that CNN
does very well in their ratings
when there's war, the Weather
Channel does really well
when there's extreme weather.
Right.
So people love watching
extreme weather--
the tornadoes--
It's mesmerizing.
--hurricanes.
Absolutely.
And I don't know why,
because it's deadly.
But maybe we just like deadly--
like, kids here like looking
into the mouth of T-Rex.
Yeah.
And who doesn't love
black holes, right?
That will rip you to shreds.
So-- so maybe there's
some morbid fascination
we have as humans with
things that could kill us,
but we somehow keep
a safe distance from.
Or fascination with scale and
power that we can't comprehend.
Energy, yeah.
Yeah.
The manifestation of
energy beyond our control.
Mm-hm.
So-- so Rad, do
you have any insights
into people's fascination
with extreme weather?
Yeah, I think we heard a
big part of it right there.
As we're getting better in
some ways at managing risk,
planning for the future.
As satellites improve, I think
it's somewhat human nature
to still be in awe
of these things
that can immediately disrupt--
At a safe distance.
Everything that-- that can
disrupt all of our best plans.
And I think that clearly,
it's compelling to study
some of these extreme events.
Because if we can
better understand
what's going to happen,
either in terms of predicting
an individual storm or how
the statistics of storms
may change in the future,
then we can reduce some
of those-- some of those risks.
But I think there's another
piece here perhaps related
which is this-- I think
we should acknowledge
this just sort of
visceral element
by which we're fascinated
by these things.
Thinking of tornado chasers.
You know, there's a
beauty to these extremes
as well that maybe we need
to connect with in some
of our messaging, too.
So our--
I think also-- also, I
think-- if I'm alone here,
just let me know.
But we're all looking
forward to death.
[laughing]
When should we let you know?
Now?
[laughing]
Let's have a talk afterwards.
No, I think-- I think the safe
distance from something that
will kill you is an
intere-- who doesn't love
sitting behind a picture window
watching a thunderstorm unfold
Right.
And maybe there's a way
we can even leverage
the idea that these
extreme events
are sort of exciting to people.
As macabre as it is, is
there a way for that to get
some people to the table?
When horrible things happen
like Hurricane Sandy,
can there be a
teaching moment after?
Where do you sometimes have
potential to, right after.
When people have seen the
vulnerability, when they're
making decisions about whether
to rebuild, how to-- how
to use that information.